on transmet tous des messages en
permanence et quand il ya un enjeu
derrière ces messages alors on a une
grande responsabilité dans la
transmission
qu'on mette en place un projet avec des
collègues qu'on explique à ses enfants
pourquoi ils doivent faire leurs devoirs
pourquoi c'est important qu'ils aident à
la maison notre responsabilité est
d'être le plus clair possible dans ce qu
on leur transmet mais comment faire
alors pour moi c'est une obligation
d'être clair je suis mines
je vois quelque chose et ce quelque
chose est tellement précis et clair dans
mon esprit que je me donne les moyens de
le rendre visible à d'autres alors que
ça n'existe pas en voilà un beau défi
rendre visite quelque chose qui n'existe
pas ou qui n'existe pas encore c'est un
tel défi que le risque c'est d'en dire
trop
et moi j'appelle ça le mime bavard et là
vous dites ah ouais elle fait le mur en
fait j'ai tellement envie de vous le
montrer ce mur que vous finissez par
voir mon souci de vous le montrer
au lieu de voir ce qui m'inspire
on rencontre tous des gens qui en disent
trop il ya des gens qui vont nous faire
adhérer à un projet devienne des mimes
bavard il y en a même qui ont le slide
bavard ils veulent tellement en fait à
force de vouloir trop en dire on voit
leur souci de bien faire ne comprends
pas leur but
ni ce qu'ils voient eux alors l'inversé
vrai aussi dans la transmission d'un
faux parfois on n'en dit pas assez
on passe à côté de l'essentiel - en tant
que maman trop souvent j'exige
obéissance immédiate de mes enfants
rangez vos chambres n'ont pas prêt
maintenant débarrassé vos assiettes en
sortant de table alors que souvent il
est plus efficace de leur expliquer qu'
il vaut mieux ranger les chambres avant
que les invités arrivent pour qu'on soit
fier de montrer une maison bien rangée
sans slip chaussette par terre ou encore
ce soir mais tous fatigués que si on met
tous la main à la pâte ça ira beaucoup
plus vite
donc tu aura passé la soirée ensuite
alors qu'est ce qui est vraiment
important dans ce que je veux
transmettre
quand j'étais élève à l'école de mime
marceau c'était incroyable toutes les
anecdotes qui nous racontait tout le
temps sur sa carrière internationale
mes enfants un jour michael jackson est
venu me voir pour qu'on élabore ensemble
son moonwalk était incroyable
mes anecdotes qui m'a le plus frappé
dans ce qui nous a raconté c'est celle
ci un jour alors qu'il était jeune et
lui-même élève détiennent de crewe le
premier grammairien du mime ya un élève
qui a posé une question dans sa classe
qui a dit m decroux au théâtre je dois
jouer le rôle d'un prêtre
or je n'ai pas la foi comment faire pour
jouer juste étienne decroix répondu mais
toi genou et la fois viendra
j'imagine et laisse sceptique
ah ouais quand je me mets à genoux
je suis plus petit que les autres et je
ne maîtrise pas ce qui m'entoure de la
même manière quand je mets à genoux
je ne suis plus dans le rythme des
autres et tout ce qui m'entoure et bien
plus grand que moi alors peut-être que
je ne sais pas ce que c'est que la foi
mais j'en ai une sensation et cette
sensation est de ma compréhension
intellectuelle
c'est intéressant de voir que la
compréhension ne se fait pas seulement
sur un plan intellectuel
d'abord je vis quelque chose et ensuite
je le comprends c'est peut-être ça
d'ailleurs une des premières clés si je
vois quelque chose c'est que je le vis
déjà alors c'est pas facile de changer
de perspective
c'est pas facile de descendre de son
piédestal
surtout quand on a un ascendant en tant
que parent ou en tant que manager quand
je mets en scène des spectacles jeux
managent cinq six comédiens sur scène
avec leurs compétences différentes
leur sensibilité aménager leur potentiel
unique et leur mauvaise foi aussi
parfois
alors je donne les indications de ma
place assise devant un pub où ils sont
sur scène mais parfois ça ne suffit pas
il faut que je monte sur scène et que je
met à leur place et leur la soie je leur
montre quelque chose soit je suis juste
avec eux mais souvent ça me permet de
trouver avec eux ce que je cherche en
éducation
il paraît que quand on a un message
important à faire passer un enfant que
ce soit dans le positif dans le négatif
pour qu'ils accueillent de la meilleure
façon il faut se mettre à sa hauteur se
mettre dans la situation d'une personne
pour mieux la comprendre c'est une clé
et ensuite on peut mieux lui transmettre
un message
ça j'ai compris quand j'avais 16 ans et
toujours grâce au mime
quand j'étais au lycée je faisais
beaucoup de théâtre et puis un jour les
parents nous ont annoncé qu'on allait
déménager à budapest en hongrie
pour moi c'était la fin du monde pas
juste parce que je quittais tous mes
amis mais aussi parce que je ne pourrai
plus faire de théâtre dans un pays où je
maîtrisais pas la langue
et c'est là que le mime a pris une
importance considérable dans la vie à
budapest j'ai fait du mime partout
c'était possible dans les parcs dans les
rues à l'institut français à l'école
française des caves et une fête et c'est
là que j'ai fait ma découverte ils venus
et net que je joue assez régulièrement
où je me réveillais je prenais un petit
déjeuner hélas si mon auditoire était
français ça se passait plutôt pas mal
mais si mon auditoire était hongrois un
flottement sceptiques se faisait sentir
les français mais entendu y voit une
baguette de pain
mais les hongrois pour le pain c'est pas
une baguette c'est une boule une boule
d'un kilo ou d'un demi kilo alors ça ça
doit être de la charcuterie
alors qu'est ce que je peux bien
badigeonner dessus
quand je mime devant un public hongrois
je dois adapter mon geste mais avant
pour pouvoir bien me mais cette boule de
pain il faut que les toucher sentir
goûter et je crois qu'il ya beaucoup de
frustration qui viennent de là où de
malentendus même quand on veut
transmettre une directive à des
collègues à des enfants à des bénévoles
dans une association sans vivre la
réalité
au mieux on obtient l'obéissance au pire
une rébellion
mais dans les deux cas on n'a pas
transmis de vision réelle et sans vision
réelle
les choses deviennent floues et là ça se
gâte et dans le mime quand c'est flou eh
bien on voit plus grand chose il ya une
dizaine d'années viennent cnet que j'ai
mis mes des centaines de fois alors
c'est l'histoire d'une intérimaire qui
arrive dans un crématorium pour prendre
la place d'un maître de cérémonie
funéraire
évidemment elle fait plein de gaffes et
à un moment donné elle flashe sur l'un
des porteurs du cercueil donc dans son
élan et se précipite vers lui et elle
réalise qu'elle est en train d'enjamber
le cercueil devant tout le monde
donc elle est gênée elle s'excuse auprès
du mort et puis elle continuer un moment
plutôt drôle et puis un jour j'ai perdu
un être cher
j'étais à son enterrement j'ai vu son
cercueil de les toucher
et depuis quand je pense à un cercueil
je pense à son cercueil et depuis quand
je mime un cercueil pour moi c'est la
même chose
je pense à son cercueil alors récemment
on a filmé cette saynète que j'avais pas
joué depuis des années et puis arrivé à
ce moment précis où je regarde le
cercueil je vois celui mon ami alors
j'essaye d'être drôle de jouer quand
même et puis là le réalisateur me dit
coupez annelot là j'ai bien compris
forcément c'était pas clair ce que je me
mets j'ai essayé de cacher quelque chose
que je voyais
et de faire comme si je voyais autre
chose est-ce que c'est pas la même chose
quand on exige quelque chose à ses
enfants sans conviction au qu'on demande
à d'autres de s'investir dans un projet
auquel on ne croit pas ça ne peut pas
marcher
je ne peux pas demander aux autres de
voir ou de légitimer quelque chose que
moi je vois sans conviction alors on a
tous le choix de ce qu'on veut vivre
voire et transmettre vous allez me dire
dans le mime c'est une évidence c'est
vrai je rend visible ce que je veux mais
en fait ici dans cette salle il ya plein
de gens qui ont des projets très
ambitieux dans une association sportive
dans l'humanitaire en organisation
d'événements comme tedx qui doivent
motiver des bénévoles et peut-être que
ces gens là sont aussi des grands
timides mais quand ils revêtent leurs
costumes
quand elles chaussent leurs talents de
12 ils font un choix dans ce qu'ils
veulent rendre visible y en a tous ce
choix là qu'est ce qu'on veut rendre
visible qu'est ce qui est suffisamment
important pour moi
au point de devoir être rendues visibles
on est tous habités par des rêves un
endroit on a envie d'aller peut-être une
compétence qu'on veut développer
quelle est cette envie qu'on souhaite
réveiller en soi pour ensuite la
clarifier pour qu'elle nous emmène au
bon endroit là où on veut être
quel est cet essentiel dont je veux me
rapprocher
si je ne vis pas cet essentiel
je ne pourrais pas le voir et si je ne
vois pas cette essentielle
les autres ne pourront pas le voir non
plus nietzsche était athée et il disait
aux croyants qui voulait le convaincre
que jésus christ était le sauveur du
monde pour que je puisse croire en votre
sauveur ayez l'air un peu plus sauvé
et souvent la conviction enfin l' envie
de convaincre sa part d'un sentiment
compréhensible mais parfois quand on
veut à tout prix que l'autre voie on
finit par l'empêcher de voir l'essentiel
un peu comme les mines bavard vivre
quelque chose pleinement le voir
précisément me permet ensuite de
transmettre avec conviction les
spectateurs et clients les collègues
pourront le voir aussi en tout cas en
avant la lecture la plus claire possible
ce qui est essentiel pour moi là tout de
suite ça pourrait être cela
peut-être que vous avez vu exactement la
même chose que moi
peut-être pas mais dans le fond peu
importe ce qui est essentiel pour moi
c'est qu'ensemble on ressente des choses
et que je vous transmettent des
sensations et vous quel est cet
essentiel que vous aimeriez transmettre
c'est parce que vous verrez c'est
essentiel que les autres pourront le
voir
merci